luego de un periplo de 50 días la
caravana migrante que partió de chapas
finalmente llegó a la Ciudad de México
este 12 de diciembre pero a su arribo se
topó con un bloque de contención de 350
agentes de la Policía capitalina que
intentaron impedirles el paso a la
Basílica de Guadalupe y querían
llevarlos al albergue que la autoridad
ha dispuesto para recibirlos al oriente
de la ciudad ante la negativa se suscitó
un enfrentamiento entre los migrantes y
los policías con palos piedras botellas
que dejó como resultado 13 agentes
seleccionados y al menos 4 migrantes
heridos después de horas de negociación
incluso con representantes de la
Comisión de Derechos Humanos de la
Ciudad de México los migrantes aceptaron
utilizar los autobuses que el Instituto
Nacional de Migración dispuso para su
traslado ordenado al templo mariano a
donde finalmente lograron ingresar
gracias a que las autoridades del
recinto abrieron
más allá del horario previsto y
permitieron que los migrantes realizarán
una oración ante ni los migrantes ni
ningún peligro pudieron en realizar la
pernocta no pudieron dormir en las
inmediaciones del templo católico debido
a las medidas sanitarias por el covid-19